an estimated 3000 young people from
Western countries are currently fighting
in Syria and Iraq jihad and Isis have
attracted many foreigners including up
to 700 from France and 300 from Germany
with the help of a common strategy
dating back to 2005 the EU wants to
coordinate the fight against terrorism
among its member states context / dental
veneer least there's hope in the
security tape after every meal illegal
not took like super coordination the
southeastern Sigma the difficulty with
the return of many foreign fighters from
Syria and Iraq
terrorism is becoming a real threat in
Europe
just remember the latest attack in the
Jewish Museum in Brussels in May this
year the European Union collaborates
with the United Nations to exchange
expertise for the UN he is the man
jean-paul aboard executive director and
counterterrorism and issue recently
debated in a summit chakuza one face it
showed to me Tom + Sookie not Hawaii the
standoff it does't resolution one
particular majesty
so a complementarity and rally to
control a tourism a little Adam Sasaki
some a little while Rome a little 168
important on a penny if a human could
not was actual one sec miss if I'm a
city important and what about the EU can
it be as efficient as the UN renewable
PN but that Pacifica's coronation Adana
Museo well at the Maria da Cunha parlay
Lina so Janelle Matt no II do CDs action
keep up Sofia comma y Lucia and Hawaii
kiddo a trophy Alamo police EEE the
limit a low risk the person versus adult
eres the EU is in the limbo in this
moment we need to have a holistic
approach to fight terrorism in a clever
way in there are many measures but they
need this holistic approach that
combines home security together with a
global security concern and and
and and of course consistent foreign
policy in 2013 along 152 terrorist
attacks claiming the lives of seven
people were carried out in the EU the
future will show if the you can prevent
the rise of a new generation of
terrorists in Europe